When using maps in your application
the map fragment provides a view
over the map, based on the
specifications defined on your camera.
If you don't define a camera you just
get a view of the entire world over
latitude zero and longitude zero.
Understanding the camera is
the key to understanding your app.
The camera is controlled using
a class called CameraPosition.
The properties that define
your camera are the targets.
And this is the latitude and longitude
that you want to point the camera at.
This lat long will define
the center of your map.
And how much of the map you
see is determined by the zoom.
This is a value from zero, the furthest
out effectively showing the whole world,
down to 21,
which is really close to street level.
You can get in even closer
by using Street View,
and you'll see that in a later lesson.
Bearing is a property, and
this determines the direction
that the camera is facing.
It's specified in degrees
clockwise from north.
So if you want the camera to be facing
east, the bearing would be 90 degrees.
If you wanted to face northwest,
the bearing would be 315 degrees.
Tilt is how much
the camera is tilted by.
By default,
this is zero which means the camera is
facing directly down towards the ground.
You can increase this with the upper
bound determined by how far zoomed
out you are.
So, for example,
if you're zoomed out really far
the maximum tilt that you
could do is 30 degrees.
As you get closer to the Earth,
the maximum tilt goes up.
With a maximum of 67.5 degrees.
You can just see tilt as how
the camera is tilted toward the ground,
you're looking straight
down at the ground, or
you're tilted at the ground so
you can get a 3D isometric style view.
Like you had with
the skyscrapers earlier on.